somebody better be bleeding broken or on
fire when the scarlet witch was on set
the fire was always brought elizabeth
olsen was constantly hooked up to
harnesses
rigged to wire tracks and suspended an
air to portray all her wand magic and
sometimes with very little to work with
visually we've got 16 of her most
impressive scenes without cgi coming
right up now i think we're just so
excited
number one
seeing red now that's just chaos magic
from the scarlet witch herself filming
the actress we get christmas-themed
colors but nothing about her performance
feels jolly olson brings the fire while
the effects team brought the visual fire
that's just very cool and it's very
satisfying number two
wanda's powers were totally
underestimated this woman's pain built
the entire city of westview a barren
construction lot is all you need when
the special effects and acting
performances are this good the 360
camera track that was set up around
olson to capture all the magic only
needed a touch of green screen to bring
the whole image to life in such a
stylistic way the cg team went the extra
mile so convincingly constructing
wanda's world with the old-fashioned
television visuals and all
number three
there was no doubt something strange
happening in the town of view this
is for us so let me
handle it reaching her breaking point
for all to see brought an incredibly
powerful performance from elizabeth
olsen and very sophisticated special
effects to show just how powerful her
emotions and chaos magic were
number four
who knew which versus which could be so
intense
[Laughter]
catherine hahn and elizabeth olsen were
defying gravity literally hanging
opposite each other on a giant spinning
rig in a set that looked more like a
construction site than a place where a
tv show was being made their major
battle took place entirely in the air
with both actors hooked up to wires and
wire tracks that allowed them to zoom
through the air smoothly
number five
her first full marvel movie she was
gonna leave an impression make no
mistake you see pictures of scarlet
witch and she's always like that when
elizabeth olson took to the screen we
got a full blast of power one of our
first glimpses of just how strong she
was came when she worked to clear
sokovia pushing through to exert all
those powers which honestly without the
cg does kind of look hilarious but her
hand movements and choreography are
still on point and exhibit all the grace
we know she has who else can cause such
damage with such elegance
number six
and she made him feel so real layers on
layers on layers of light ray visuals
came together to create the single
powerful image as we see the vision we
all want to see come to life
we'd never have guessed that in reality
the room was pretty empty save for those
green screens three-dimensional models
were rendered of each actor to bring
this unique transformation
wanda's powers are really all out for
this one and who can blame her the
scarlet witch was ready to be seen
number seven
the power hands choreo just keeps coming
almost anyone else would look ridiculous
doing these intricate and delicate moves
but olson pulls it off like a natural
that's what makes her unique no question
she's the perfect scarlet witch it's not
just shooting energy towards robots
there's some things that haven't that
aren't just about like being harmful her
powers really can do it all defending
and battling sure but her ability to
move objects and help her cohorts out
when they need it makes her that much
more powerful who else could give the
cap such a solid boost
number eight
is this the most boss lineup we've ever
seen we're marveling hard at these
female avengers strutting on a set that
honestly is pretty amazing as is
sure they weren't all actually in the
room together filming at exactly the
same time but we get the point it works
everyone's just kind of taking their
turns moving around trying to help each
other out the cg team's job was much
easier working with this as a base as
well everything had a way of coming
together pretty seamlessly
number nine
having to go through it again and again
that's gotta hurt
just as quickly as he came back into her
life he was gone and in an incredible
visual display thanks to the cgt
what started as a green screen became a
multi-layered image to bring both
realistic backdrops and the extra magic
on top it was painful to watch but that
light brings the beauty
hello again
how long do we think these two were
standing together in such stillness for
this painful moment to be captured
number 10
no one was going to keep her away from
vision when she wanted in wanda got in
no need for huge displays of power a
simple hand gesture and some red cgi
light added to the picture are all you
need when you're the scarlet witch
window busting piece of cake render some
shattering glass visuals and we're all
set
number 11
wanda's powers came with the help of a
whole lot of crew members since the
style they were looking for was a pretty
specific kind of movement that's a
surprisingly hard thing to do in cg
puppeteering for real was the way to go
meanwhile special effects could help
hide all those real wires it was pretty
hard to ignore for the actors since they
had crew members getting right up close
and personal with them and the floating
props items were hooked up to the floor
hanging from the ceiling across rooms
whatever they needed they rigged it and
to add a bit of extra pizzazz the cg
team would sprinkle in some janky moving
items to blend in with the image
number 12.
wanda wasn't about to waste any time
getting back to work she already had
that fantastic scarlet witch suit on so
why let it go to waste green screen boss
outfit the signature glowing red cgi
perfect setting for reading the dark
hold and planning her next steps now
that she'd embraced all that chaos magic
power the possibilities are endless
props to olson for holding that
cross-legged position while rigged to
those wires for so long number 13
when they want to stop the train better
stop or else they'll make it
luckily the train they were stopping was
already stopped and still on set making
the job a whole lot easier for them but
a bit harder for the cg team to make it
look active mix in those powers from the
power sibling duo and they were set blue
and red lights have never been more
powerful
number 14.
crew assembled the airport fight is on
even with the tech and green screens
around it looks like this was an epic
day on set
that many stars running together that
much power that much talent that's
enough on its own plus they all really
bring the heat on this one olsen was
ready to fight we'd want her as a
teammate any day
number 15.
in coming it's a wander flying in olson
got used to being in a harness for
filming the better half of the last few
episodes of the series she was swooping
in with all the grace in the world toss
in the jazzy red glow hands to spice the
picture up and we're in business even
when she's wearing sweats
number 16
it's a whole new world live in color
four different colored versions of the
images were combined to create that
tv-like texture the twinkle effect nod
to that era of shows made for a perfect
detail thank you cg team oh not to
mention that extra upgrade that came
along slick and convenient assembling of
furniture
when elizabeth olsen is around you know
a scene is going to be good when the cg
team is on the job you know the scene is
going to be great
some of these scenes look incredibly
different without the cg but the way
they set the scene for the team to
capture all they do
well they make it work which scene did
you think looked the strangest behind
the scenes